hormis les piccoli d'abord on va dresser
tout de suite la fiche vous ne
reprendrez après si je me trompe
michel piccoli voix hilarante trois ans
à l'air john holmes ça ça arrive oui pas
encore comédien né acteurs affirmé al
palmarès tout à fait extraordinaire
débuts au théâtre dans le matériel
humain au cinéma avec chicago digest en
1953 michel piccoli loup avec jean marie
serreau le théâtre de babylone ayez
interprète notamment mademoiselle julie
de strindberg
puis ces franges cancan la compagnie
renaud barrault et des films en cascade
parmi ces derniers jean passe rafle sur
la ville le bal des espions le doulos le
mépris compartiment tueurs le coup de
grâce benjamin belle de jour la chamade
de cela près qu'il avait tout dit j'ai
pleuré lundi à l'ats non mais j'ai
oublié sûrement des tas de choses ne
rigolait c'est d'ailleurs les débuts
c'est pas tout à fait ça je crois le
délai nous les débuts remontent à 48
j'avais un directeur de théâtre je me
souviens qu'ils étaient encore en
uniforme d'officier ffi alors ce domaine
45 où il ya soyons francs c'était lors
quelle pièce c'était une pièce qui
s'appelait le jugement dernier c'était
les hommes qui venaient lui qui montait
au ciel jugé dieu et ça se passait au
garage
je ne sais pas quoi saper le garage
c'était le théâtre pigalle toute alerte
rothschild tout à l'heure c'est dingue
dizier j'ai 43 ans mais j'ai un peu le
palmarès de dunedin est ce qui hélas est
mort ça cela veut dire vous avez fait
beaucoup de films vous avez beaucoup
tourner et vous êtes devenu vedette un
peu tard
oui oui tarawih fait à part trop tard je
suis encore en bonne santé heureusement
non mais enfin il ya combien de temps à
votre avis que vous existez sur le plan
du cinéma sur le plan du théâtre sur le
plan notoriété surtout au théâtre ça a
commencé avec une pièce de georges
arnaud qui s'appelait les aveux les plus
doux et au cinéma ça a commencé avec le
doulos de melville fois ça a commencé ce
sont des accidents qui ont fait que ça a
commencé mais comme ça avait commencé
bien avant c'est dur d'attendre le
succès par moments oui mais on n'attend
pas que ça finalement vous savez qu est
ce que vous avez pensé parce que c'est
que le succès qu'est ce que vous
attendez du théâtre ou et vous ne savez
pas ce que c'est que le succès parce que
vous l'avez maintenant oui mais que je
me demande comment il est arrivé
vous vous étonnez toujours je m'étonne
un peu et en même temps je m'étonne pas
trop parce que comme c'est venu comme
quand on grimpe à la tour eiffel si on
pour l'ascenseur n'arrivant on est
ébloui on a le tournis tandis que moi je
suis passé par les escaliers alors j'ai
eu le temps de prendre mon souffle et
vous avez beaucoup d'optimisme non car
alors oui heureusement alors vous avez
beaucoup d'années don juan à la
télévision michel piccoli vous est à la
ville un homme rangé à l'époux fidèles
et me dit oh un moralisateur éloquent
elles seraient bien sûr puisque tout ce
que donjon un ton moralisateur l'eau
quand j'en suis là forcément oui mais
dans la vie comment êtes vous dans la
vie on a tendance à dire que je suis
triste et ennuyeux et je me trouve drôle
vous voyez que je me mouche pas du tout
c'est jean marie ou doux qui dit que
vous êtes à milly ennuyeux un anneau lui
match je trouve étonnant on a toujours
bien ri ensemble il ya une phrase de
vous qui m'a toujours un peu étonné je
me demande si elle est vraiment de vous
oseriez qui parait-il
je ne cherche pas à séduire je séduis
naturellement
oui oui c'est douteux là comme phrase
non pas du tout mais j'aimerais que vous
confirmer la nouvelle mais parce que je
trouve que de séduire c'est c'est de ne
pas séduire
qu'est ce que c'est un séducteur dans
vos on s'éteint mais d'abord vous
demandez ça moi parce que je suis acteur
et on croit qu'il n'ya que des acteurs
qui n'ont s'éduque s'est pas seulement
pour ça car michel piccoli zoom stasi
pour le séducteur type oui parce que l
écran est ce que je suis allé travailler
la chance de jouer dont jon monsieur
molière qui devait a beau séducteur
celui là aussi mais ce qui m'amuse c'est
que on croise n'importe qui dans là je
dis bien n'importe qui on s'aperçoit
qu'il était aussi séducteur que monsieur
kagan ipek pour palm sur l'a6 où
monsieur appelez-moi son nom on assiste
à l'allaitement
vous trouvez que c'est un séducteur la
conasysed mais certainement mais la
séduction c'est quoi à votre avis j'ai
l'impression que les hommes ne s'occupe
pas assez de leurs femmes ah ben ça
c'est toute la question ça vous est
demandé absolument oui ils n'ont plus le
temps
ils doivent produire qu'ils vont des
nouilles ou qu'il vente du théâtre il
faut produit à tout prix l oeil non plus
le temps de se distraire actuellement à
séduire se distraire si vous deviez
donner un conseil aux hommes pour leur
apprendre à mieux conserver leur femme
est ce que vous diriez qui le qu'ils
plongent un peu à la paresse et que
cette paresse il la remplissent avec
leur femme michelle beagle et on va
revenir à cette histoire de séducteur
enfin à la séduction en général je pars
du principe que les rapports entre les
hommes et leurs épouses ne sont pas ce
qu'ils devraient normalement être bien
sûr parce que on ne prend plus le temps
de vivre
là c'est un peu publicité à ce que je
dis pas ce que j'ai vu a fini à soi qui
s'appelle le temps de vives qui n'est
pas encore sortie qui est très beau
stade de ce problème
passons sur les publicités mais continua
le sujet mais de toute manière vous êtes
d'accord avec moi pour dire que les
hommes ne sont pas ce qu'il devrait être
avec leurs épouses mais l'entente du oui
parce que je crois qu'il ya décalage
complet maintenant avant
une certaine époque les pouces pour les
conventions sociales matérielles ou
morales l'épousé tu es un peu finalement
l'esclave de l'homme qui tel maître de
la maison
mais comment vous avez dit que
maintenant les femmes sont capables
d'être comme nous avocats conducteur de
tramway ou pilote de ligne alors ça fait
peu un peu aux hommes ça les étonne mais
c'est une manière de normaliser les
choses que de penser que les femmes
doivent être exactement comme les hommes
si on leur donne les métiers comme ceux
qu'elles ont maintenant c'est un peu ce
ne sont pas exactement ceux ci justement
c'est là où on se trompe parce qu'on ne
comprend pas qu'une femme puisse cet
avocat est en même temps une vraie femme
là c'est ça ou le c'est là où le william
petit déclic à enclencher qu'il faut que
les hommes arrivent à reconnaître qu'une
femme est capable de faire ce qu'il fait
en même temps que c'est toujours une
femme qu'elle fonctionne toujours comme
une femme le portrait d'un séducteur est
toujours quelque chose de spécial par
exemple si vous faites la cuisine vous
vélo mais là je suis encore démodé c'est
ma femme qui fait la cuisine
bon c'est un mélange à peu près normal
alors contrairement aux apparences
complètement normal oui bon vous avez sa
part été sans mal vous avez épousé
juliette gréco et vous la connaissiez
depuis très longtemps que c'est qu'il
possède entre le moment où vous l'avez
connu le nom vous l'avait épousée mais
je les connais je l'épousé en même temps
psy je l'avais jamais rencontré
précédemment
jamais non je vais
je l'avais entendu chanter et puis
j'avais entendu parler d'elle mais c'est
tout oui aux aguets même dit pour payer
pour pourvoir gréco moi je paie j'ai
beaucoup payé pouvoirs locaux et
maintenant ça sert ambages contenu coupe
commencer la vie d'un séducteur que
michel piccoli qui est marié à une femme
qui s'appelle juliette gréco c'est quand
même deux monstres dans un même foyer de
monstres monstres en guillemets avec le
tout le côté glorieux non pas péjoratif
oui oh pas vous pourrez ça peut être
péjoratif si vous voulez aussi ça on
sent des goûts très bien payé est ben je
crois que les deux monstres ils
s'amusent tous les deux ensemble en
reprend en pensant à ce qu'on dit d'eux
ou ce qu'on a dit 2 à tort ou à raison
est-ce que nouvelle amusons de ça est ce
que vous faites des critiques est ce que
critiquer ce qu'elle fait toujours dans
le bon sens bien entendu mondiale de ses
chansons ou pas du tout ça elle
n'acceptera pas elle a raison mais non
mais on est très soucieux de du travail
de l'un et les par exemple les choses
que l'on pourrait faire soit et qui nous
ennuie complètement
on a tendance à penser à le dire pour le
travail de l'aude alors que pour soi
même on ne le fait pas du tout vous êtes
de ceux qui pensaient que une femme doit
faire quelque chose et non pas rester à
la maison en bas elle ne peut plus elle
ne reste plus à la maison c'est fini oui
parce que vous vous êtes dans un cas
tout à fait particulier juliette gréco
michel piccoli sais pas car nous nous
c'est autre chose nous nous courons nous
courons au moyen de pouvoir rester à la
maison c'est autre chose tu avec les
autres général cours pour ne pas rester
à la maison
michel piccoli etes-vous jaloux oui
normalement jaloux je crois je crois
tout à fait normalement vous avez tenu
les plus belles filles du monde dans vos
bras
est ce qu'il ya et il y en a une qui
mériteraient d'y revenir si j'en prends
une les halls vont mais sharp & dohme
doute millions de faire des cas d'espèce
une belle mériterait tout
on y reviennent sauf que moi je reviens
plus particulièrement avec une c'est
catherine deneuve comme ça oui c'est
vrai vous avez tourné au moins quatre
films avec lui c'était à asa et
maintenant c'est une habitude si l'on me
pose beaucoup cette question pourquoi
tous les goûts et catherine deneuve
s'est en même temps c'est un tig
beaucoup les gens sur tous les plans est
là il pose des questions comme ça peu
insidieuse et pourquoi tournez-vous tout
le temps et catherine deneuve
je leur réponds la vérité c'était à
s'arrêter à agen c'est une habitude
on peut donc rétablir la vérité il n'y a
rien entre michel piccoli et catherine
deneuve une ya une complicité
professionnelle qui s'arrête là
d'ailleurs aussi beaucoup étonné de ne
pas vous voir de mayerling parce que
vous avez pu tourner le rôle que tient
en art sharif
vous auriez des records avec catherine
deneuve très bien c'est vrai vous n'êtes
pas de toute manière pour les rôles qui
demande beaucoup de cachet c'est lorsque
je dis cacher je veux dire argent car si
mes souvenirs sont bons vous refusez
beaucoup d'argent lorsque vous propose
des films
je crache pas sur l'argent mais c'est
très très dangereux l'argent pour un
acte et parce que quand il commence à
gagner beaucoup d'argent
il fait n'importe quoi pour gagner de
l'argent et il oublie qu'il faisait ce
métier pour autre chose je gagnais de
l'argent parce que finalement tous les
actes et à peu près tous font ce métier
là où des pas pour pour un tas de
raisons
c'est le simulacre sont des enfants
éternelle il rêve mais une pense pas
tellement l'argent par exemple je vous
offre 50 millions pour un mauvais film
où le tour n'est non pas du tout non
pourquoi parce que vous n'aimez pas la
facilité
d'abord je n'aime pas la facilité je
n'aime pas ce que je pense qu'il est
mauvais le ferai pas et puis et puis 50
millions c'est mirifiques mais ça ne
suffit pas vous avez vous aiderez co et
par le fait même vous avez deux enfants
maintenant penser à l'avenir
oh oui absolument je vais commencer à y
penser c'est à dire est-ce que vous avez
déjà prévu une petite cagnotte pour les
pour les vieux jours
non je peux j'ai prévu j'ai prévu une
maison pour les vieux jours nous de
maison mais sont déjà installés jardin
ça évolue bien de quel moteur il doit
voir des immeubles partout
vous avez vraiment des immeubles partout
absolument pas jaloux violent pas la vie
en particulier nono nous battre et c'est
trop quoi en voiture quand même une
voiture oui mais je crois que je vais
trouver un nouveau système maintenant je
vais vendre la voiture que j'ai pour
changer autre une voiture qui sera louée
alors maintenant une question très
indiscrètes
vous valez combien par film n'aura votre
avis jose d'où il devait pas nourrir
d'abord je ne vous répondra pas parce
que moi même je ne le sais pas parce que
si j'ai envie de faire un film qui me
plaît énormément pour peu d'argent je le
ferai et il peut arriver qu'on me
proposait un film pour beaucoup d'argent
alors je ne sais pas ce que je vaux
j'avais c'est à la tête du client et le
client n'est pas seulement l'acte est à
la tête du producteur à la tête du
metteur en scène surtout un film avec
monsieur houston
en oubangui chari je sais pas pourquoi
choisit du grand duché l'autre côté
safari sabawi sûrement qu'on gagne
beaucoup d'argent si je vais tourner un
film avec marco ferreri par exemple et
qui j'ai tourné en italie quoi ta phin
retourner un budget de 52 millions
pensait bien connecteurs belle pas
énormément d'argent mais vous allez
tourner avec hitchcock ce sera votre
première aventure américaine là ça
mérite le cachet oui mais ça c'est un
peu par la petite porte si j'ose dire ce
n'est pas le rôle du film de hitchcock
mais ça j'aime bien tenté les aventures
et puis
la petite porte avec hitchcock c'est
quand même pas la petite porte non plus
faut pas exagérer c'est d'ailleurs si je
dis par exemple que michel piccoli gagne
30 million par film je ne suis pas très
éloigné de la vérité
pas très et dans un sens et dans l'autre
tout à l'heure lorsqu'on parlait des
femmes vous aviez tenu dans vos bras
j'espère que vous allez me parler de
bardos et razimbaud c'est roger inscrit
tout de suite vous m'avez parlé de
catherine deneuve qui laisse à penser
qu'un homme je pourrais parler de
beaucoup d'autres j'ai ouï brigitte oui
je les tue nos débats j'ai pas tu
dormais badea c'est faux sa faillite est
l'échec de ma carrière c'est à dire mais
j'ai tourné avec elle un film dans
lequel chaque fois que je vous demandais
venir dans mes bras elle me disait non
tu me dégoûtes vous voir les pas content
pour un acte est ce que ça peut être
comme handicap que de tourner pendant
une douche tous et pendant une heure et
demie avec brigitte bardot et qu'elle
n'arrête pas de vous dire je te méprise
je ne veux pas de toi ça peut vous
ruiner une carrière à tout jamais je
l'échappée belle de toute manière cela
par une haie votre vie vous avez encore
un bel enthousiasme
ah oui ou non mais au contraire de
tourner avec elle l'a peut-être aux
contrats aidés à ma carrière ça c'est
certain vous trouvez que c'est une
grande vedette brigitte bardot ah oui je
veux dire une grande comédienne une
vedette elle est bien sûr d'une grande
comédienne mais c'est une comédienne
c'est pas une grande comédienne busco la
décla l addec live dette et que vous
savez bien que intrigante comédienne et
vedette ce sont deux mondes différents
et catherine deneuve c'est une grande
comédienne seule ça oui c'est à dire le
parallèle est toujours amusant un fumeux
mais elle est là réussira sûrement à
faire un noeud avec les deux vous êtes
allé tout récemment à bruxelles et vous
avez vu l'homme de la manche derrière la
création de jacques brel
mais qu'est ce que vous en pensez ben je
tousse tous que jacques brel et
extraordinaire nous bien que c'est pas
nouveau mais c'est un peu nouveau parce
qu'il ne fait pas que chanter il joue la
comédie aussi et comme je lui ai dit ça
fait 20 ans que j'apprends à jouer la
comédie et lui
la répéter pendant deux mois seulement
ça m'a un peu agacé vous n'en voulez pas
tous ces chanteurs qui se met à jouer du
tas faire du théâtre à faire du cinéma
or pas du tout ça casse pipe elle
travaille avec des gens comme bâle
serait plutôt tendance au contraire à
l'améliorer mais de toute manière ça
peut vous enlever les rôles dans
l'avenir vous aimez vous savez s'il
fallait penser à ça il n'y a plus qu'à
s'arrêter
bon mettons qu'il y ait trois metteurs
en scène devant vous oui cela s'appelle
michel cournot l'autre jean luc godard
et le 3e michel audiard lequel vous
aimeriez tourner le godard godard mais
invaincu j'ai déjà tourné avec lui je le
connais très bien là ça serait une
vieille habitude donc il reste les deux
autres michel cournot et michel audiard
oui vous sentez bien dans la peau
l'hérault qui pourrait vous faire jouer
je suis pas un mec audi a6 est un
personnage si je peux bien triché faire
ce que je veux oui vous avez vu son fils
faut pas prendre les bourgs eux n'en
fait pas moins de pression de pavage
vous avez vu le film de corneau les
gauloises bleues oui vous l'avez trouvé
bon une chose qui m'a gêné ces jeux
c'est un film d'une grande tendresse et
on a presque toujours qu'il se défende
cette tendresse c'est ce qui m'a agacé
le cinéma d'aujourd'hui c'est quoi
provoquer un cinéma bien installé c'est
un cinéma qui a une certaine gueule
vous savez le cinéma d'aujourd'hui c'est
comme le cinéma dié vous parlez de la de
cornaux et de et de godard et d'audiard
mais avant vous aviez au noir en
éclairer duvivier c'était
c'était un peu le même éventail est ce
que vous ne souffrez pas un peu en ce
moment de ne pas faire du théâtre si si
beaucoup oui car dans le fond vous êtes
un homme de théâtre michel complètement
oui mais un moment j'étais un peu saturé
tellement j'avais joué deux pièces
vraiment saturé et puis j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir faire du cinéma dont
je fais du cinéma mais maintenant
j'aurais plutôt tendance est saturé par
le cinéma et je vais vite retourné au
théâtre un petit peu non mais il ya une
chose autrefois vous n'aviez pas 40 ans
donc faisait vous faisais du théâtre et
vous n'aviez pas peur de perdre de
l'argent
aujourd'hui j'ai passé des rois rempli
puisque je ne gagnais pas de toute
manière aujourd'hui vous voulez en avoir
ces deux là pour ça que vous avez choisi
le cinéma au lieu de choisir le théâtre
non à une époque je vais sauver le
cinéma y est beaucoup plus longtemps
parce que je ne gagnais pas l'argent le
tat qu'on m'a proposé de faire du cinéma
et que j'étais bien content que ça me
met de l'argent mais c'est d'aider ce
moment là que j'ai compris que c'était
un attrape couillon je ne sais pas si
cela était fo d'inigo mais joyeuse et je
précise l'ined attrape nigaud on va
parler un peu politique à l'ancienne
c'est pas si vous êtes passionné par la
politique non je le crois oui si on va
parler d'un problème qui peut vous
intéressez-vous michel piccoli en tant
qu'acteur il y a eu le festival de
cannes le festival de cannes est tombé
dans une période que vous connaissez oui
il a été tué d'une certaine manière par
des messieurs qui s'appelait claude
lelouch pour jean luc godard louis malle
louis malle d'ailleurs recevait sur son
yacht
claude lelouch partait mais la ferrari
et jean luc godard qui disait une fois
plus faire de cinéma par les installer à
londres pour tourner un film
mais est-ce que vous pensez que ce
festival de cannes mérite d'être repris
en 69
oui mais sûrement d'une autre manière je
ne pourrais pas vous parler du festival
de cannes cas je ne suis jamais allé je
sais que c'est une c'est l'équivalent de
la foi de lyon la fois du textile c'est
pas du tout méchant ce que je dis c'est
la fois du film comme il est la fois
lutter long de cette exacte de leur
salut va à bordeaux et on vend le plus
possible de fin août chine et il ya des
gens qui pensent que
la première qualité d'un film ce n'est
pas d'être vendu très cher ou pas cher
c'est la qualité du film tout court
vous êtes contre les festivals je ne
suis pas content le festival je ne crois
pas mais aussi dans le fond je suis
contre les festivals je suis jamais allé
je voulais pourquoi parce que d'abord je
mets le film qu'elle est au festival
et puis alors un acteur aléas festival
alors qu il n'y participent pas chou ça
grotesque
s'ils vendent vedette soit il pour la
publicité c'est bon mais quelle
publicité à publicité c'est qu'on voit à
l'écran que le public vous plaisir au
public c'est tout il n'y a pas de
publicité en dehors de l'écran
à votre avis y en a mais je crois que
les dangereuses est pas suffisante du
tout parce qu'on voit beaucoup de gens
qui a beaucoup de publicité on les voit
jamais à l'écran ou très peu à laquelle
les gens qu'on voit beaucoup à l'écran
et année le jeu mais je publicité sur
mais vous avez des noms grillades et non
la dont le moment vous voyez pas je le
dirai si me venait à l'esprit mais
je les vois pas non par exemple par
exemple gunter sachs par exemple j'ai
rien contre monsieur gunther sachs un
des dernier festival de cannes on n'a
parlé que de lui et on n'a jamais rien
vu de lui alors qu'est ce que voulait
qu'un acteur viennent faire là dedans
vous tenez à préserver votre intimité
dans le faux oui intimité activités
intime si je puis dire et l'intimité de
ma profession
bon c'est un peu éloigné de la politique
oui mais qu'ils annoncent que c'est sur
moi politique en plus le festival de
cannes bon alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé à votre avis est-ce que c'était
valable
est-ce qu'il fallait tuer le festival
c'était sûrement valable puisque
monsieur oloa fin déclarations dans le
journal le monde et pas très longtemps
et il a reconnu que tous les travaux des
états généraux parce que là du festival
de cannes c'est un des accidents qui
fait partie de ces états généraux du
cinéma qui ont été ce qu'ils ont été
mais quand même passionnant et monsieur
hulot le directeur du centre national du
cinéma a déclaré que ce qui s'est passé
aux états généraux était très
passionnant très intéressant donc que
vous voyez que je n'apporte rien de
nouveau
j'entends duo tour en disant ça au cours
des états généraux car je les ai suivis
c'était parfois passionnants gérez vous
ce titre une fois etc sans dîner un
champion du des réflexions assez assez
extraordinaire par exemple celle ci il
faudrait que tous les comédiens à tous
les chanteurs soient payés de la même
manière
est ce que vous seriez d'accord pour
qu'on en arrive là moi je suis d'accord
enfin c'est il faut s'entendre sur le
prix non il faut pas s'entendre sur le
prix mais il y a une chose par exemple
que des gens gagnent énormément de
l'argent pourquoi pas par exemple si
monsieur chevalier est tout seul sur une
scène et pendant un mois ils remplissent
les salles c'est normal qu'ils mettent
l'argent dans sa poche puisque c'est lui
qu'il gagne
oui ça fait à peu près 50 millions
d'ailleurs sa dernière aventure très
bien mais un film c'est pas du tout la
même chose maintenant un film c'est une
tente est aussi bien pour un producteur
c'est un c'est une course aux mirages
extraordinaire là pourquoi les acteurs
ne participerai pas à cette course aux
miracles mais à d'un autre côté en
général les producteurs se méfie
beaucoup de ça parce qu'ils aiment bien
acheté une marchandise et puis après
c'est tout moi je pars du principe que
si on fait les gens de la même manière
c'est vraiment la solution de facilité
on va directement vers la médiocrité au
nom de payer de la même manière dans
l'eau nous il ya forcément un par la
suite une sélection dans tous les
régimes comment l'accès aux états
généraux ou alors tous les régimes qui
souhaite toujours nu qu'il y a toujours
une sélection
donc il serait possible de travailler de
cette manière là mais en faisant des
fiches comme les fiches que peut
organiser cravenne il y aurait ce qui va
là au dessus de 20 millions on savait
que ça existe déjà
nous sommes déjà fiché les acteurs donc
arrivée à tanger du val de france 50 ce
qu'ils valent cette fois 50 ce qui va le
10 x 50 et ceux qui parlent 102 millions
est-ce que vous avez été concernés par
les événements de mai en dehors de votre
métier de comédien en complètement oui
comme tout le monde d'ailleurs mais
maintenant personne n'ose l'avouer
michel piccoli vous êtes très intéressé
par la participation des acteurs
l'industrie cinématographique oui ça ne
paraît pas sérieux devant les vrais
financiers du cinéma parce que on dit
que les acteurs gagnent beaucoup trop
d'argent est évidemment il naquit déjà
beaucoup trop d'argent par rapport à
d'autres mais ça c'est un mystère qui
est facile à cléré droit devant je crois
que le fossé est justement à cet endroit
où les producteurs et distributeurs se
rencontrent je ne sais pas si les
producteurs elles disent hipster se
rencontrent crois qu'ils sont surtout à
couteaux tirés en ce moment mais ce que
jamais vous estimez que les
distributeurs ont quelque chose à voir
dans l'organisation d'une profession
comme la vôtre
oui puisque ce sont eux finalement qui
décide un peu de la fabrication d'un
film
ce sont eux qui avance de l'argent aux
producteurs ce sont eux qui tirent les
copies quand le film est distribué
il ya toute une série de gens qui ont
beaucoup de trésorerie vous voyez ce que
je veux dire oui alors on pardonne à
part ça coûte beaucoup d'argent ils
dépensent beaucoup d'argent et ce sont
eux qui qui fabrique un film ce genre de
aussi qui décident du choix d'un acteur
d'une vedette
lorient n'a que vous avez raté a marché
pendant deux mois mais ce le
distributeur de metz du jeu celui là
lorsqu'on dit par exemple de bardos
aujourd'hui elle ne vaut plus rien sur
les distributeurs les producteurs ils
disent ça je ne sais pas chez par
l'ostau qu autre chose est appelée
légende ça parce que comme c'est une
très grande vedette et que maintenant il
a d'autres qui sont aussi très grandes
vedettes ont dit elle est tombée mais
attendait peut-être qu'elle va remonter
c'est comme belmondo on l'a dit pendant
un an et ne fait plus rien pourquoi il a
des ennuis
et puis patatras que booth comment on
lui qui veut aller voir des films de lui
dans la festival un festival à belmondo
treize films mais tout ça c'est aussi à
cause de cette côte d'argent qui a chez
les acteurs qui ça ça ça brouille les
cartes
vous aimeriez qu'il y ait un festival
michel piccoli ans que l'on renvoie là
pas du tout ah non vous êtes contre la
personnalité fait de ce côté là ils
voulaient plus beaucoup trop peur de ce
que quand je fais quelque chose mais
j'ai aussi peur qui a 15 ans et je vois
pas pourquoi maintenant commencer à
faire un festival autour de moi quoique
je ne comprends ça maintenant que quand
un choix sa mort lié à un film que vous
les tournées qui s'appelle la chamade
oui le film sort cette semaine vous
considérez que de tels événements
humains dans demain mercredi précipitez
vous pressez ah bon parce que si tu est
terminée mais vous voyez vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure vous avez horreur
de la publicité ça par exemple c'est
bien fait c'est direct bien enlever
c'était gros c'était gros c'est être un
gros mais il ya déjà des critiques
qu'ils ont sortis sur la chamane par
exemple j'ai là en face de moi un
article de claude mauriac je vois déjà
les quatre premières lignes ont fait les
quatre premières lignes prises dans le
papier car le papier très long on dit
michel piccoli nous révèle une nouvelle
fois l'étendue de son talent et la
profondeur de ses dons mba merci à
claude mauriac ça vous plaît
j'aurais mauvaise grâce à dieu ça me
plaît vous avez bien compris son article
car c'est l'article il veut dire entre
l'article entier non je n'ai pas très
bien compris il faudrait leur lire trois
fois à tête reposée voyez par exemple le
titre de drôles de gens qui ont une
drôle de vie c'est la chamade
moi je trouve que ce sont de drôles de
sons de drôles de jeunes ont fait des
jeunes sont des gens tout à fait
quotidien finalement vous êtes d'accord
avec l'article de mauriac
excusez moi mais il faudrait vraiment
que je le relise vous l'avez lu combien
de fois déjà une seule fois à manger cru
je croyais avoir compris d'hôtel
vous avez dit je les lui trois ans nous
faudrait alors ya trois fois il faut le
lire toi froid parce que il mélange le
monde sagan est ce qu est le travail de
cavaliers alors il ne sait pas s'il doit
aimer sagan aussi louer mes cavaliers
files étaient réticents et en même temps
je dois dire quelquefois un peu
chaleureux quand même de toute manière
dans l'achat mal est quelque chose qui
est grave c'est qu'on n'oublie
parfaitement alain cavalier pour ne plus
parler que de françois c'est dans
attendez attendez que le film sorti je
crois qu'on parle toujours de france à
sagua comparé à beaucoup de la cavalier
michel piccoli catherine deneuve
toujours et toujours oui le prochain
film c'est pour quand tous les ans je
crois que tous les deux nous jouerons
dans 20 ans sur le banc nous allons
voler un jeune sourd aux as et raymond
souplex leurs pièces célèbres nous
jouons sa voûte à de la porte
saint-martin en 95
mais juliette gréco nous ne nous a
jamais fait reproche de tourner aussi
souvent avec catherine deneuve et
pourrait voir la com
le rapprochement elle le voit aucun
rapprochement non élucidées là ac oui
elle ne vous prends pas elle pour un
séducteur le j'espère que six places et
comme vous êtes dans la chanson michel
piccoli puisque vous êtes dans une vraie
chapelle avec juliette gréco connaissez
bien ce milieu une cathédrale nos
orgueils majestueux le budget est ce
qu'à votre avis c'est l'avenir après je
ne suis pas de parti pris est ce que
votre avis et la fin juillet
feuillet déjà c'est un mot qui est qui
est mort depuis deux ans mais par
exemple les jurés françois johnny
hallyday riche en automne ils ont encore
une chance à richard anthony sûrement
mais les yéyés s'est passé à la fin
c'est la saturation pour l'instant alors
il faut qu'ils se dépêchent videur d'un
tracé là bas s'ils veulent pas que ce
soit la fin de toute manière c'est une
époque après les yéyés y aura autre
chose lui les zazous les yéyés demeurent
les togo togo
en quoi c'est une chose qui m'étonne
pourquoi n'avez vous jamais chanter
parce que j'avais d'autres chats à
fouetter
nous avons essayé pourtant une fois à
une fois où j'ai chanté je voudrais
c'est excellent je chantais une fois à
bobino je me souviens adamo débuté
j'avais eu autant de succès que lui à
l'époque c'était assez sérieux c'est
bien en quelle année je sais pas quand
cancan adamo a débuté à paris fin mai je
peux lui avoir 6 ans je pas où ça compte
pas stern n'avait pas eu de chance il
n'y avait pas à ce moment-là à bobino
talent scout c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle le graphe un imprésario qui qui
permet de déchiffrer les talents et y
avait des gens du disque comme on dit là
qui m'ont dit mais voulait pas faire des
chansons et encore dernièrement et des
gens qui connaît c'est tout un autre
métier bruno coquatrix ne vous a jamais
proposé par exemple un duo à l'olympia
gréco et piccoli pour la première fois
non mais lança capables les patrice et
mario de la fantaisie non non mais
j'attends sa proposition de toute
manière maintenant on va résumer un peu
la situation michel piccoli nous avons
passé une heure ensemble une heure qui a
passé plusieurs années alors je
répondrai pas faire un scandale est
bloquée l'antenne comment on pourrait
faire vous pouvez je ne sais pas vous
savez vous si on peut il ya deux choses
vous pouvez me dire - michel piccoli
j'épouse demain gréco syrie libre et je
divorce ou alors je suis sur le point
d'épouser la reine d'angleterre je veux
renouveler le coup de n'assiste alors là
aucun problème pour ça a marché tout de
suite je peux pas vous dire quand même
que bientôt madame n'assiste pas d'y
voir si pour moi mais volontiers je
répondrai volontiers julien jacquot mais
là avec alors à falbalas fantastique et
à lire les grandes orgues de la
cathédrale tout ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure
beaucoup de garçons d'honneur de filles
d'honneur oui bon alors on se résume un
peu vous êtes c'est lui que vous êtes
séducteur oui je ne suis pas que ça
atteint der garde
regarder la télévision dans pas
longtemps que vous allez voir vous êtes
jambes et le fidèle je suis quand même
fidèle oui mais c'est n'est pas exaucé
je suis séducteur cesser ces
professionnels si je puis dire et puis
vous êtes quand même fidèle je suis
quand même fidèle vous n'êtes plus
libres qu'on le sache bien le nom qu'on
en parle et je crois que vous êtes quand
même disponible veut pourquoi disponible
à quoi
[Musique]